because there's still some racism out
there you know and I'll name a couple of
groups that do not get along really well
black and white Chinese and black
also Mexican and black in prison okay
and this is all stuff that I've heard
from verified people and the rumor is
black verse alien or extraterrestrial
ETS you know I have a lot of black
friends that have told me that there is
low-key beef between extraterrestrials
and the urban community lot of white
people in here huh
you know who you are okay you glow in
the dark I see you all right I like
white people man they're cool you know
but they're hard to stereotype like
other cultures other ethnicities easier
to stereotype you know Asian people eat
food with sticks drive like that's their
gimmick okay Mexican people either build
a nativity scene in the dashboard of
their
car or teach their kids to beat things
with sticks until they get what they
want out of them
like pinatas and
tourists yeah black people either dance
really well or walk extremely slowly
across the
street hurry up black people okay but I
don't blame y'all for walking slow I go
slow too if I to wait for a little
blinking white guy to tell me I could go
it makes sense people I'm just sharing
things with
you oh it shocked people even my mom was
like what is happened
son are you getting enough Sun that's
what she said you're strangely tan you
look like a guy that should be much
whiter than you are and you and you know
that and you know that yeah boy yeah
what's the deal dud are you outside a
lot huh are you out Inside Man part of
my family is from Nicaragua bro and
that's not a racial story yeah my
father's from Nicaragua what yeah nikara
bro where my nit Gars at huh
well a little too close okay all it's
yeah and hopefully the audio is clear on
that it's okay I got get your back who's
a c in there and the man went out in the
world and did the world work and the
woman stayed at home and took care of
the family work and I don't think it was
ideal for anybody but the the kids were
fat and the cat was fed and you got home
from work and your wife was standing
there with the mail and she's like tell
me what the mail
says and I'm not saying it was perfect
I'm just saying that it
worked and then women started wanting to
do everything
everything we want to chew gum uh we
want to wear hats we want to drive big
rigs we want a
CrossFit crossfitting what the [__] are
y'all doing y'all are doing chinups in
an abandoned shed all morning we're
[__] starving at the house our boy
can't
read and you're worried about muscle
density when I married you had a ass now
you got glutes what are
glutes don't make that thing any harder
for Daddy to get Ino yeah I grew up in a
mixed neighborhood dude and uh black
people don't really know they don't
differentiate between indoors and
Outdoors what do you mean Outdoors can
be indoors dude what do you mean
Outdoors can be indoors black person you
can put them outdoors and you put them
indoors same volume levels same speed
there's no inside voice there's no
there's zero inside voice there's no
etiquette when you go indoors well they
just don't I don't I don't think they
believe in like a lot of structures and
I don't I don't want to say woodwork but
I want to say overall that they the
difference between indoors and Outdoors
when it comes to most so incredibly it's
so incredibly vaguely racist so funny
though but yeah I think the best way
probably to introduce a Filipino to some
whites well uh God I think first of all
reveal do a gender reveal that's what I
would do hiding behind a tree let
everybody in your family guess what
ethnicity he going to be and then run
him out there so that's what I would do
I would do a ethnicity reveal where you
put him in a box or put him behind a
tree and then you let your family guess
what ethnicity is going to be and then
get one of those smoke things and maybe
it makes I don't want to say yellow
smoke I mean that's you can't do that
that's racist um just you know what
don't do the smoke thing have him come
out from behind the tree and say here he
is a black friend told me that Chinese
people are like the black people of Asia
is that true or is that what is that
have you ever heard that do you just say
Chinese people are the black people of
Asia yeah yeah aside from the fact they
don't have black dicks Chinese don't bro
who's going who who's got that large
meat on the Asian side oh Filipinos for
sure cuz they're mixed in with
like yeah dude cuz the Spanish cuz they
were like invaded so much occupied bro
that like you know you get invaded
enough you'll get outad right
in the Filipino hole oh you know how
babies are made right and they squirt
inside right and then and then thud the
[__] dick oh right so you know they were
colonized places that are colonized are
mixed in with [__] M I wish black
African nations colonized more yeah cuz
maybe I'd have a bigger dick they do a
little bit they have the bar Clay Center
I don't if you've seen that if you don't
have any black friends then you never
seen how black men can really get into
some rib dude black guys should be uh
bone doctors or something I'm surprised
there's not more black surgeons cuz you
see a black dude get into a thing of
ribs bro a black guy crack a rib open
and do they got meat in there first of
all get a black friend order him half a
rack of ribs and see what he does that
dude will have them dry at the end of it
not a meat not a not a gristle a black
man could dip a rib that he ate into a
fish tank and not even a little fish not
one fish will swim up to even look for
anything cuz there's nothing on it a
black guy you know will really put that
gang bang on a rib have you ever been to
SeaWorld nah no no never been H I know a
lot of people I actually watched the
documentary on SeaWorld what was it on
how they were um what's it called Zach
black fish yeah yeah what is it it it's
about like how they the whales and
captivity yeah it's how they treat black
fish dude that's [__] unreal bro is
that what it's
about yeah yeah the [__] yeah it's
called Blackfish damn bro you
see bro y'all can't even cat break under
it's not just humans it's not just
humans say somebody's hanging out with a
Muslim so I'm hanging out with like fem
anoir okay yeah yeah so and somebody
Drives By in a truck right because it's
always a truck I guess that RAC a truck
TR and yells out uh get out the street
slim they call them Slims a lot of times
wait wait wait they call who Slims
Muslims no they don't yeah never you
hav't I feel like you mix it up dude but
what I'm thinking is the best way for
any racism to occur that it shouldn't
occur it should never occur right but if
it has to occur in the world the best
sometimes it has to right well I don't
know I don't is that what you're saying
sometimes it has to I don't look I don't
I think a little bit keeps thing it
keeps you know it keeps the engine
running it keeps yeah and let's don't
use the term
engine songs on the radio sounding fake
Prince and Genesis were better
anyway
anyway am I just being to real or is my
mind
going obtained somehow some of the worst
looking women I've ever seen in my life
man dude I look I love and
man it's Hur it hurts me to say it but
some of the women you're like dude no
wonder
they I if I if those were the women I
had to be around uh
visually I would go around and enslave
the rest of the world as like teens and
stuff I mean your sister's friends would
come over and just oh my God just seeing
them lay around by the pool or like
watching a television on the couch you
would be like this is the most exciting
thing that's ever happened dude I
remember a girl ask me to hold her
necklace while she swam one time and I
[__] masturbated like three times oh
yeah cuz I just had never even held
something of a woman's for a while I
totally understand I remember hiding in
my buddy's hamper at his house just to
smell his mother's
bras and I'd hide in there for aing hour
and just Huff those cups yeah so what
kind of girls you like oh man I like all
kinds of girls really big small sleeping
um who hasn't uh dated a lazy Eyed Girl
for a little bit don't laugh man she's a
hell of a ski
shooter that's my favorite joke man I
used to get mad and get up in her face
and go pull and just watch her eye go
out like
that that's my favorite joke but uh
I don't know man I like to date a
homeless lady man cuz after the date you
could just drop her off
anywhere but I like I like a I like a
strong girl you know I like a a sturdy
gal man uh you know kind of girl who you
know get into some things you know what
I mean these skinny girls man like
making love to a can of Pickup Sticks
you know I'm serious man it's like
making love to a pillowcase full of deer
antlers I need a freaking sturdy man I
need a girl that's got a little har you
know I need a girl that's got some in
her you know maybe a little decent in
the tank kind of girl that just snatch a
goat off a bridge if she has to you know
kind of girl that gets in with some
things you know what I'm saying these
these skinny girls just don't do it for
me man um I got a girl for you you do
yeah she's got a speech impediment she
does this a
lot if if she can cook I will take
her I'm serious I'm serious Michael a
lot of women don't cook anymore man and
here's my thought it's true gentlemen
look at us hungry clap you hear that
hunger
clap you hear that hunger clap and
here's my thoughts Ladies If God didn't
want you to cook then why did he
naturally put milk and eggs in your
body ingredient people ingredient